welcome to this video playing maradona
Iceland luck do something else here the
drum and Bob scheme why not try
something else 97 interesting oh maybe
he can do some some stuff with e five
now yeah yeah that's really possible
Queen a5 these kind of things hmm
probably that wasn't a very precise move
order okay maybe 92 okay just want to do
something else for a change 90 f three
should be three maybe okay you can just
take everything off actually after in
flag Bishop d3 yeah I wonder if I should
take with the night as silly as it looks
but maybe the night be three helps me to
get rid of this pin maybe it's not great
but I have misplayed a term anyway
d 593 and if it takes Queen takes Queen
takes King takes you 5 95 should be good
yeah at least okay I'm not to worm
ambitious here after this somewhat that
maybe I mean I'm not so bad in terms of
development now he has moved his pieces
so quite a lot in a row e 595 is really
silly for for black and I think I'm time
what should he do actually maybe taking
but then I'd be five again horses the
king move so bad him probably this
wasn't the way to go for black
hmm yeah it's taking some time it's not
it's not so comfortable um yeah might be
five them to force the King to move yeah
and now I thought c5c 5c 594 takes takes
King c3 King c6
I think taking is better really taking
and deform this is just just good or
Bishop c4 also what's good f7 is also
hanging but ok you fall it's not a bad
moves i think i just want to get looks
to see one and a d1 quickly so trading
or not no probably not yeah i want to
prepare what you want that if he takes
Bishop takes check must be excellent
I'm not sure if King III was so great
but ok let's not be too critical about
everything here so I'm going to take and
he might come to be six when possibly
the bishop here would have been would
have been good ok so i can give this
check now
maybe maybe this move i attack this pawn
on on e6 e6 I have Roxy one which is
threatening a huge discover check and
King King to be six especial de diya
yeah he he rented to this check this is
now I mean black resign yeah that that
was a full-fledged opening disaster some
how I felt like I miss played it but
maybe it wasn't so bad this is still
normal i believe 97 and maybe maybe now
this is this is not so precise i thought
i thought what actually was more afraid
of is this and then maybe e5 stuff like
that does this irritated me a lot to
this Bishop before here now maybe maybe
it's not not a huge problem i can still
protect things hmm maybe he can also do
this which is obviously very aggressive
now possible i want to check this but I
think I'm okay and now yeah night x is
good yeah that was good to know that i
spotted that I mean this is not so
convincing he can play whatever now I'm
not not really forcing matters but after
night take this is this is now already I
think a big problem not be five is so so
when I'm annoying I really don't see
what he is playing now what is the comp
giving plus 14 y damn it is really a bad
bad position check and this is again the
best move and now Bishop c4 yeah this is
stronger I was pretty much quickly as i
saw it quickly after I played the form
but okay yes still excellent look see
Bishop c4 and now he cannot really he
cannot protect you can i play f6 and
then I wanted to go look see one go from
them yeah something something like that
i'm not sure which will gradually maybe
this one I don't know and King King them
and I have a huge development advantage
problem is that i'd like to do this and
give a check yeah but the king is in the
way still maybe this this and our King
and Bishop f2 I'm just controlling
everything here yeah but this is ran
into this ran into a total disaster and
here he resigned yeah after that I have
firm many nice ideas of course I
wondered what I wonder what is the best
one actually I thought that maybe I yes
Bishop c5 check actually so ever like
this this isn't that isn't so clear mmm
looks terrible but it isn't so clear
this may check check check check and now
this is this is a maid yes check check
check mate that's cute ok so he has to
go here check check this might be
interesting playing for checkmate them
Bishop e7 and things like that wow
that's really really terrible
the cop wants to do this yeah this is
this is really really not very nice yeah
fun game okay thanks for watching